it's Villa hamdullah Salam alaikum
laughs love October I'm here at Eddie's
and I'm gonna give him a whooping he
never is gonna forget you watch and show
some peace be on to you we have an
exciting show for you today it's very
difficult out of times the rat race of
life you got so many things distracting
you people calling you to go to the
nightclubs you got promiscuity all over
the place but you know what there's
something missing in your life you don't
have peace you don't have contentment
the dollar is not giving it to you
you're running from boy to boy girl to
girl you know you're just dating and all
this other stuff but you know something
is there in your heart you want to
change you know that look there's no
other than the one God the one God who
created this whole universe and
everything in it and he's got a system a
plan but you away from the bet game plan
because there's a lot of distraction
we're gonna be talking about some of
these distractions and how you can get
more serious because death is a reality
we're all gonna die
it can happen today it can happen
tomorrow it can happen after the show is
finished so we really have to take the
matter seriously but we know it's
difficult it's a jihad it's a struggle
to be good to develop yourself to be the
best human being so we're going to get
some advice from our next guest Sheikh
Autobots sit tight right back
this is the thesis but the
assalamu alaikum peace be unto you and I
concealed my flying over Turkey thank
you thank you very much fine time view
for us here on the Deen show people dud
Deen show.com to read a little bit about
you and to see some of the other shows
that we've done with you but wasting no
time time is short time is short and the
matter is serious you know we get a lot
of emails and people want to change you
know they watch some of the shows and
they come from other ways of life and
they see these things you know they
don't make sense God being a man
Trinity three-in-one someone died from
them says God come into suicide you know
or they feel like you know what I didn't
believe in God but my innate nature cell
telling me there is a God but you know
when the going gets tough then they get
going but then when the the new
girlfriend pops up or they get invited
to the party and they start to talk
about these serious thing it's not the
cool thing money fast cars distractions
so we want to help to give some
encouragement you know how can people
really take this matter seriously and to
get on the ball because Islam is
something rational is logical if you
take the time you'll see that this can
come from no other than a creator of the
heavens and earth and some people have
even acknowledged this but they're
having a hard time submitting and doing
all the good things that God Almighty
has tell them to do because they got
other things on the mind a guy can't let
go of the girl to go can't let go the
guy they don't want to get married at
doing it
test-drive style so how could we give
some real advice talk to us talk to us
please I've come to be having a good out
of me I was listening to you and it's
vertical of vehicle you have a good
description of what's going on out there
but the person first should be patient
with himself you know and we should be
patient with each other a laws messenger
says mommy no I didn't mean in Allah
with them there is not a believing slave
except that he commits a sin
Phaeton bought a thing time after time
again or he commits a particular sin and
he never stops doing that sin until he
leaves this dunya the fact of the matter
is that Allah created man sinful and
forgetful either Lew Kyra Becker when
he's reminded he remembers and this is
in the Quran we are lost of Hanukkah
with Allah says in a genuine Fela our OD
halifa I'm making in the earth a Khalifa
a deputy the angel said called Watauga
al goofy hey man you see goofy how're
you speak with me man are you going to
put something in the earth you're gonna
put someone in the earth who's going to
cause corruption and spill blood so the
intrinsic nature of man is to be
mistaken and cause corruption and do
things wrong so when he realizes that
either lukina Ducker when he's reminded
though he remembers you know and that's
what we have to first and foremost
understand that we will fail when we
take Shahada we say I swear in a
children's poem called children's fit it
says I swear to do a laws command and
not to do one thing Haram that's what we
say in the poem teaching the children
how to you know understand if they're
fit and that's what everybody says I
swear to do a laws command and not to do
one thing Haram but when I fail I will
repent before I get a punishment from up
above Allah Most High before my soul is
cause to die so the third first thing
that we tell the individual is that you
will make mistakes as a human you're
going to make mistakes
however don't be wrong and strong repent
as soon as you realize you're making a
mistake
turn to Allah repent don't be like those
people saying Noah's not allowed to say
I will repent
maybe one day for those who think like
that will find the devil has possessed
his mind he plans to drop his soul in
hell
turn to Allah to break his fell say I
start for love how wa atubu ilayh that's
all the Muslim has to say so I'm not
going to approach it first by saying
you're not going to do any wrong you're
going to do ruin you're going to fall
victim to your ego and your desires
sometime so since that's the case I'll
be enough like that no we've been taught
how to respond when we made a mistake
and that's through repentance repent to
Allah and a stub federal law I seek the
forgiveness of Allah what a tubal la and
I turn back to alum and recognize that
I'm the slave of Allah because that's
the original thing that we recognize
that we're the slaves of Allah
we're not talking about someone who
doesn't know this we're talking about
someone who knows this so this is the
case we have to repent and after we
recognize that that we're going to fail
and then we're going to repent but we
just need to reminder and that the
reminder benefits in the dhikr attempt
element meaning that the reminder
benefits the believers then we do with
the advice of the Prophet said he said
be around those who make you shy okay
stick with those people that make you
feel shy to do those things why don't
you go and make you know zina with your
girlfriend on the minbar because you
know that the people are going to stop
you physically so then you need if
you're feeling these feelings and these
are not unnatural feelings you know
then you need to stick and be around
those people that are gonna make you
feel shy and we could talk further about
other things that people can do to
distract them from these distractions
because allah subhanho wa taala says el
hair como tu casa you know getting a lot
of things accomplishing a lot of things
distracts us ya hectares or to one of my
carpet until we visit the graves so you
know the way that we people are
distracted look at the beautiful skyline
this is a whole wheel and it'll distract
us going out to this place and going out
to that place but we play a role in our
own destruction because we are attracted
to these things and these things keep us
from focusing on the real
what's the real deal the real deal is
that we are living in a temporary
situation that eventually is going to
end and then the real situation the
long-lasting situation is going to
become our reality it's and so we're not
told to live and not have fun there are
lots of things we can have fun with but
we're only been told to stay away from
those things that's going to harm us in
this world and in the Hereafter so these
things like someone who quate like Haram
are harmful things things that are
prohibited and that's God's law because
God knows best along those best is that
right right so these things are bad for
us anyway like you know okay you have a
natural desire to want to be with the
man a woman want to be a man want to be
with the woman and a woman want to be
with the man but not outside of marriage
so if you have this this this desire
it's not something unnatural but now to
go and sleep around with someone who's
not your wife or your husband you don't
want to do that listen Allah Subhanahu
WA Ta'ala says no quarter Anzu Gina
linetti
o shahe we're teaming and he said Allah
says that he made men desire woman and
made woman desirous and men want and
distant and lust after these women you
know however so the desire for a man to
be with a woman and a woman to be with a
man is in the Quran yeah so it's a
natural desire a lawful desire however
you're not supposed to fulfill that
desire except through certain ways like
you're hungry right you don't eat with
your foot you don't stick it in your ear
and you're higher up your nose because
it doesn't help that way yeah you put it
in your mouth and you chew it and you
cook the food before you eat it you have
to marry a lady before you can be with
her and she has to married a man before
they can be together otherwise you're
going to get sick just like if you eat
the raw meat and the raw food without
cooking it or cleaning it and doing the
things that are supposed to be done
before you eat we can understand that we
need to understand in the metaphysical
world as well yeah
listen let's take a break we'll be right
back with more here on Adi show I just
want to say very simple message is the
leading one of the beautiful things
about our religion of
is the emphasis on direct ritual and
prayer God directly there is no
intermediary the lights will go on after
the party and the party will end it's
very simple and very clear there are no
superstitious rituals no strange
incantations the time is running out and
you might not make it till tomorrow
and this is something that we need to
think about
back here on a Dean show and we're
talking to sheikh abu Toba and living in
the real world we got real situation is
tough you got a lot of fitna a lot of
trials a lot of tests you got a lot of
things tantalizing you calling you and
say sometimes you're burning up inside
and so we want to give some some some
some good advice so you'd mentioned
marriage get married if you feel in this
now could someone you mentioned how
merciful Allah dude the loving God that
we worship you know Allah he's most
merciful and there's always hope you
started off with that can someone use
that as an excuse when they know that
fornication adultery this is something
that is not acceptable in Islam some
major sin because someone use that now
they know that and then they go commit
the crime in the center ahead well God's
most merciful he'll forgive me because
he's full of Rama he's full of mercy and
then they go and do that continue to do
it not lowering their gaze and then
acting upon these desires what do you
got to say about that
okay what I say about this is that as
Muslims we have to recognize and
understand the purpose of life the
purpose of life oh ma khalaqtu l-jinna
wa l-insa illa li Abu doon Allah said
I've not created the genies or the
humans for any other purpose except for
to worship me right then after that
Allah tells us a story of the atom and
the Shaitaan and how the Shaitaan is
jealous big jealous of the human being
that he was given this position that the
human really doesn't understand how he
gotten in shape on fields he deserves it
more so then Allah says well another the
one knocking Bechet in men and how he
will do it you are nuts in middle my Lee
when I'm Lucy with Tamara well but
surely somebody he says I am testing you
so then we realized when after
understanding that we here to worship
Allah that this whole life is just a
test Allah says AHA see Vanessa and
utricle Angulo a man a woman a afternoon
Allah says this man thing he's going to
be left alone on just his statement that
he believes in Allah and he's not going
to be tested and I said we have tested
those that came before and we're gonna
make it clear those people who are
truthful to their pledge their oath and
those who are liars you know and they're
not going to be truthful so that's the
the one aspect of it that you can't
you're not going to
get away with saying okay Allah is
merciful but he's testing you and if you
fail the test then you open yourself up
to the punishment although the results
of failing the test and you're being
tested daily and he told us how by by
your desires okay so you repent to Allah
and you try and strive your best to move
forward you know as we said again in the
children's poem repentance will not be
correct until I'm sad and feel regret
for what I've done and I declare not to
do that sin again repentance will not be
correct
until I'm sad and feel regret for what
I've done and I declare not to do that
sin again and if still sinning I must
stop all sinful deeds right on the spot
you know and so that's that's the
conditions that a person has to have for
making repentance but let's look at it
another angle okay we don't want to just
be you know responsive we want to be
proactive it's Lam does not say you
can't get married
it's nan does not say you can't like
girls and you can't have fun you want a
woman go get married that's a protection
for you you know get married and laws
must be promoted it get married and have
lots of children this is the thing and
you know you strive of course the man
has to be able to take care of his
family there's other other things he can
do to with his time
look what ad is the most important book
in the world we say you know that the
most cradle Heidi Heidi Muhammad the
most important and the best speech is
the speech of Allah in the Quran so
anything you want to learn is in the end
instead of watching a 30 minute sitcom
where you you know it's corny you know
what's going to happen it's basically
wasting your time and distracting you
you can sit down for that thirty minutes
and memorize three lines or five lines
of Quran and that will not only help you
in this world protect you from what's
going on is a lot of fun because you now
you know something that you didn't know
before and it'll be something that you
can use in a hereafter also you can
learn how to fight a lot of guys
nowadays you know you have to MMA you
know though was it minute much mixed
martial arts martial arts you know so
you can get involved in some sports not
just sport yeah
but positive sports you know just going
out and on that same basketball is bad
but if someone jumps out to beat you up
especially nowadays with all the Islamic
phobia and everything that you need you
want to get a wife you better learn how
to protect your wife you know you want
to be Muslim you better know how to
fight and the Prophet SAW I Salaam he
promoted us learning how to fight and
how to defend ourselves not to be
bullies but so not to get bullied
there's a lot of bullies so we don't
want to get bullied your hands up you
have no right to touch me and now you
have a right to defend yourself it's a
god-given right it is a god-given right
and it's a lot of fun a lot of fun for
brothers to learn how to wrestle and
even sisters to learn how to fight and
protect themselves we hear about things
girls get me a key Maz pulled off and
they can know how to protect themselves
just so they can get away we're not
promoting women fighting guys on the
street anything like so this would be
something where now you can do something
positive you can get involved and okay
the study circles be around like you
said righteous people people who make
you feel shy offended people did the
ways to Allah amilia do a guy came to
Imam Malik and he said you know what you
run your mouth too much and he mad Malik
was a famous scholar he said you talk
too much
Eman Malik you're always giving classes
and sometimes you're wrong you come back
and you change it to precision and they
mem Malik responded saying the ways to
Allah on many set off the most a team is
wide and smooth some people get there by
fasting some people get there by giving
charity
some people get there by cleaning the
message it some people get there by
doing oh there's so many different
things by offering Salah you know some
people go there by teaching and I'm
pleased with the way they'll are made
easy for me so I'm suggesting to young
people and old people and people in
general you can learn how to fight you
know if you don't like fighting then you
can go out and get some food you like
cooking and go give food to the poor you
know yeah so you can feed the poor you
mean fighting like martial art I mean
martial art like the self-defense right
like martial arts you know yeah it's
like like I know martial arts I I heard
you know martial arts but I don't I
don't know about that yeah yeah we
I like to see for myself you know I like
to take you that but I challenge you
oh let me shout you right now let's go
fight so we can see who is the best
right here oh no we got a challenge it
shattered I'm dropping the gauntlet hey
your martial arts it's no good you must
be ready to die we're gonna have to take
a break and see what corresponds from
here we're going to have to maybe right
now on today's show we're gonna have
some fun more Capone Alberto go and sit
tight and for the upcoming challenge
statue 18 inch by accept we'll see what
happens to Eddie on the Dean show when
outside everything looks good you see
this hundred thousand dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here our job to go
into someone's heart to change their
heart your job is to totally worth the
truthers and then the out of it is while
we're sitting here while I'm sitting
here constantly paying for the disease
to cure with free
yeah they don't even know what it means
I'm putting on a fake fur reason they
need to stop time I'm already stopped me
and I'm already on the straight line I'm
already repenting for spitting flower
lies already planning to quit rapping
bro I've got mine don't worry about me
worry about you I'm in alarm you sit a
little beside the record labels assigned
to Allah
I'm worshiping God this still worship
your car bro I'm a Muslim you don't know
what you were just lost cloud on a road
tryna be a star screaming now you're
talking a little boys game you need to
get serious about using your brains I
wanna hear about your life how you doing
all your pain how you do your for fire
talking back in their brain Madonna that
before always sat beside new I know you
guys are used to fly some guy
tune in every week
with Eddie back here on the Dean show so
what'd you think did you have a good
time with the fun man hum the lava rock
elephant I'm hungry later I was going
easier and you don't want to you know
ambass you on your own show Veronica
love you come had a great time
the hungry leg rabbil alameen and as i
hope that the people get to see
everything all fun that we had and the
things they can do and hope people come
and learn about yeah definitely you know
we got to work up a sweat
you know you burn some calories you get
in shape and some of this negative
energy frustrations you know out there
you get to let it down a positive way
yeah and you learn how to defend
yourself mashallah yeah so this is some
offend myself yes oh yeah I mean you've
been doing martial arts for a long time
now you're also you know a black belt is
that correct yes sir
yeah so people can now do Islam do God's
thing I call it you know submit to the
one God and it's not boring is it well
it's not as a complete complete you know
complete religion and that's the thing a
way of life I should say you know it is
the religion of Abraham we express
ourselves in our way of life as the the
deen of islam submission total
submission and if a nation wants to know
what do you mean by the religion of
ibrahim the religion of Abraham is her
not fair a brightness so we're upright
individuals staying on set off the most
arcane
and practicing our way of life of Islam
submitting totally to Allah and allows
messenger taught us that the only reason
he came with Tim a classical so that we
can perfect our character you know so I
can said I had a great time I appreciate
I like to come back over time you like I
really you know I had a great time we'd
love to have you back before we close up
just a couple more points so you
mentioned it's not man is this true that
that's how when you do this submission
is that the only way that you can truly
have peas not because people confuse now
you know a good time they might have a
good time some fun at the nightclub but
then they go home crying because they
got used and abused or you know they
spent all their money and now they got a
hangover and they still ain't feeling
that peace and that how is peace now by
doing this completed hearing submission
to God's will not your desire right
hamdulillah I wish we have hope time to
finish this this is lamb is submission
the share funny tricks to people and
saying do whatever you want and you will
find you'll be fulfilled people want to
get high okay
that high that euphoria that they feel
through submitting to Allah but it's not
to be found so they play the music they
dance everybody looks all happy and
everything but they're really not happy
you know the guy drinks the beer the one
guy who sued the company in Texas he
said I drank the beer it made my breath
stink it made me sick and I didn't get
any girls good case you know I think
because it's a lot but this is the same
thing we share thought he's a great
advertiser but he never fulfills warning
the only way you will find true peace in
the word Islam does not mean peace it
means submission surrender surrender
your ego surrender your right to your
own decision to do whatever you want and
do what Allah has decided for you to do
and then through that route of
submission you'll find peace and you got
the peace right so it's acquired piece
of quired by sort of submission to the
one God not your design don't just do it
don't just do it do what Allah wants you
to do and it's not Burger King have it
your way
no it's God's Way you got other God's
Way yes yes okay so we covered a lot and
we showed that one Avenue of having fun
you study you want to be the best doctor
the best lawyer whatever it is and now
you you study the Quran the verbatim
would have got we can have some fun we
showed one way get involved in
martial arts learn how to defend
yourself and that's not waste of time is
it kinetic also be a fact of worship it
is an act of worship you know it's the
thing with an intention a normal mundane
act becomes an act of worship yeah
okay so walking if you walk into the
Masjid because your intention is to go
to the magic it becomes a good act and
an act of worship so when you're
defending yourself you're learning
you're doing this thing practicing so
you can defend yourself and protect your
family from harm
this becomes an act of worship we gave
one example and I'm sure there's some
other things that we could talk about
we're out of time thank you may god
almighty the creator Allah rewards you
thank you I mean we're good thank you -
Salaam alaikum alaikum Salaam October
character and we started with peace we
end with peace and remember what we said
we said look you're not going to get
peace by going to the nightclub paycheck
to pay ship paycheck chasing the dollar
chasing the material world have this
world and your hand not in your heart
because when it's time to say bye-bye
when it's in your hand you can just let
it go but if you've attached yourself
and it's deep down in your heart and
that's all your focus on is Cash Money
cash money club club party party at the
end you're going to lose this world and
you're going to lose the hereafter and
you're going to die in a bad state in a
state where your Lords not pleased with
you because you didn't prepare you
chased your lusts and desires your whole
life and you didn't take life seriously
you didn't truly find out what the
purpose of life is and then you didn't
live it you lived according to your
desires and you didn't live according to
God's will it's nom submission to the
one God and that's how you have peace
that's how you have peace worshiping the
owner of peace and not his creation
we'll see you next time
God willing until then peace be unto you
I see I seek refuge with mercy on us o
be You Lord submit to him a poised the
danger of the major sins obey your Lord
repent to him avoid the danger of the
major sins obey your Lords render to him
avoid the danger of the major sins
mercy on the souls ablaze the footsteps
of Shaitan which plotting scheming 24/7
trickery deception falsehood lies
anything to keep you in the firing line
you have to pray as if everything
depends on a market it does but you must
work that's my point you see the same
and I don't like that I don't like a
sitting here what are you waiting for
what are you waiting for right now what
are you waiting for all these people
that come to this huh what are you
waiting for what are we waiting for
right now when they're gonna come
they're gonna come to log on bring these
people lost upon the water put in our
hand the ability to do it do your job
you